today i'll tell you the story of lab  grown mini eyes  or optic cup organoid this was  discovered by professor yoshiko sasai's  lab and this is one of the articles from  the nature  organoids mimic an organ in this case it  will mimic the developing eye  the starting material for organoid is  embryonic stem cell  and these embryonic stem cells are grown  in specific dish to create these kind of  organoid in order to grow this organoid  you have to provide specific  instructions  specific morphogens and eventually this  organoid would show  i like organization which has all the  cell type present in our retina or in  our eye  amazingly these kind of technologies can  be used in future  for treatment of eye and it would  revolutionize the medical science  subscribe for more